Speaker 1: And, of course, the misinformation
that was flowing during COVID has not slowed
down. In fact, it has gotten worse. According
to a new report from Im Booth Health, a study
called the Pharma Brand Dimock. More than 1000
demographically diverse adults across the United
States were polled. And here's what they found.
The overwhelming majority of respondents, 88%,
have encountered health care, misinformation. And
nearly three quarters, 73%, are anxious about it.
More than one in three believe they come across
false health information almost every day.
So health. Misinformation.
Speaker 2: In case you haven't noticed.
Speaker 1: Is growing out of control. These these
alleged crackdowns by social media outlets and
YouTube like, oh, we're not going to let all this,
you know, misinformation out there. We're finally
taking down the massive anti-vax Facebook page
that should have been taken down two years ago.
That, by the way, that group, the Children's
Health Defense, I think they made, what,
$6 million last year, I think is what I had
read. They make a lot of money, whether it's
6 million or not. They do make a lot of money.
Speaker 2: And they were removed because Facebook.
Speaker 1: Finally said, we think this is
misinformation. We've got polio in New York.
That's what medical misinformation does. A
million people dead from COVID in this country.
That's what medical misinformation does.
Speaker 2: But that's not even the
striking part of this study from in booth health.
Here's the striking part to me.
Speaker 1:
Separately, we also this from The Daily.
Speaker 2: Beast, by the way.
Speaker 1: Separately, we also surveyed 101
full time health care providers. Almost all 99%
of them said they have patients share
misinformation every week. And 90% of
medical professionals are anxious about
this. Nearly half, 48%, say they now have
less confidence that patients will comply with
their recommendations. Perhaps unsurprisingly,
the same percentage of patients, 48%, say they
are now more comfortable challenging their doctor.
So all of this misinformation and there's another
part to it other than just misinformation. I
get to that in a moment. But all of this
misinformation, what it's doing right now,
according to doctors and health care workers,
is you've got people walking into the doctor's
office. The doctor says, okay, look, you have this
problem. We're going to do X, Y and Z. We're going
to get you fixed up, hopefully, and we're going to
make you better. And the patient says, now, hold
on there, Jack. I may not have gone to medical
school, but I saw on Facebook right from this
this is very important group. They've got like 10
million followers. They say, you're wrong. They
say, give me the horse medicine. That's what I
want. Maybe I should have gone to the vet instead.
And the doctors, they can't do anything
about it. They can sit there and say, well,
as somebody that went to medical school and have
been practicing medicine for a couple of decades,
you're wrong. Please do what I'm saying.
And then the patient leaves and half the
doctors are like, Yeah.
Speaker 2: That person's
not going to listen to me.
Speaker 1: Doctors are getting.
Speaker 2: Burnout from
this. The report also states.
Speaker 1: Because you know why the burnout
happens? Because when that patient that doesn't
want to take the doctor's advice, because they
know better. Because they read it on Facebook.
They don't listen.
Speaker 2: To the
doctor. They get worse. They come back.
Speaker 1: And no matter how many I told
you so. As the doctor gives, the patient
still insists. No. I'm still right. I may
be on my deathbed because I didn't listen
to you, but darn it, I'm still right.
Until, of course, their final moments, as
we saw plenty of times during the pandemic,
people on their deathbed saying.
Speaker 2: I wish I had gotten the shot.
I wish I had taken this seriously. I wish
I hadn't followed the misinformation.
That's what we're seeing in this country.
Speaker 1: And as I mentioned, there's another
part of it, too. It's not just the misinformation.
It's the overwhelming amount of information. And
that overwhelming amount of information I'm
talking about is coming from the drug companies
themselves. Another thing that's happening
that's also frustrating doctors to no end
is the fact that we have direct to
consumer advertising of prescription drugs.
Speaker 2: Here in the United.
Speaker 1: States. And what's been
happening for 20 years now. Is that patients going
to the doctor's office, not waiting for the doctor
to tell them what they need, but they go in and
act like they're ordering at a deli. They say,
Hey, doc, you have got these problems, but I saw
this commercial on TV. I want that drug. I want
that thing. The people in the commercial looked
all happy. They're dancing. I want to dance.
Give me the drug. And if you think I'm making that
up, go and look through all the studies from the
last 20 years that have shown that people are
now walking into the doctor's office demanding,
Give me this thing I saw on TV. Which is why
we're one of only two countries on the planet,
New Zealand being the other one that even allows
that to happen in the first place. The direct
to consumer advertising. That's where we're at
today. We're inundated with news from Big Pharma
saying, hey, you need this drug. All these
people in the commercial taking it. They look
happy. They're fun, you know, they're living
their lives. Don't you want to live your life?
And then on the other side, you have people
saying, oh, no, you don't need any of this.
What you need is to go out there and eat a
couple of handfuls of dirt and that'll make
it all better. Don't don't trust Big Pharma.
And so we are stuck in this in-between.
I have seen again through my work for
almost 20 years with with various law firms.
I've seen the documents from Big Pharma.
These folks are scumbags up and down,
no question about it. They will lie to your
face about a drug that is going to kill you
and tell you it's the only thing you ever
need to take. And you're going to be great.
It is difficult to trust these individuals.
At the same time, they do still produce
life saving medication. So it's easy to
see how you get to that misinformation.
There is a lot of distrust there and there
should be. Because, again, a lot of the people,
including some of the prominent anti-vaxxers,
they fought these companies in court.
But it skewed them to the point where
they now believe you can't trust anything.
The truth is somewhere in between.
And unfortunately for doctors.
The public doesn't know what to
do. They don't know who to trust.
We're just kind of left in the middle. Big
Pharma is greedy. Big Pharma rips us off. Big
Pharma tries to sell us drugs we don't need. But
they also make things we do need like vaccines.
And life saving medications.
Speaker 2: That we just wish
we could afford to.
Speaker 1: Take.
But then all of that greed, all of those
horrible documents feeds into the you can't
trust Big Pharma. They're only out to kill
you. Misinformation. It's a vicious cycle.
And it is almost.
Speaker 2: Entirely
a uniquely American cycle.
Speaker 1: We have to take another quick
break. I am fair and cousins find me on Twitter,
Instagram and Facebook at Farron Cousins. I'm in
for David Pakman this The David Pakman Show.
Speaker 2: And we'll be right back.